remis à toute une surprise en ouvrant
son courrier une facture de 900 $ de la
ville de sainte anne des aigles rené n'y
habite pas mais il ya six mois il a eu
un petit accident d'auto dans cette
ville l'autre conducteur impliqué arrête
appelé le 9 1 1 les pompiers sont
présentés même si ce n'était qu'un petit
accrochage les pompiers avait débranché
les batteries des véhicules
tout la facture de 900 dollars le
gouvernement québécois permet d'éviter
d'imposer un tel tarif mais il y à des
conditions la santé ou la vie d'une
personne ne doit pas être en danger et
les pompiers doivent prévenir ou
éteindre un incendie
heureusement pour rené son assureur va
payer cette facture puisque les dommages
sont véhicules sont couverts mais si
rené n'avait été assurés d'un bord comme
on dit il aurait dû assumer lui même la
facture si il avait été déclaré
responsable de l'accident le fin mot de
l'histoire le 9 1 1 si nécessaire mais
pas nécessairement le 9 1 1